c'est une confidence qu'on ne pensait
pas entendre omar sy et nerveux quand il
présente un nouveau film à saint quentin
en yvelines
et pourtant l'accueil est toujours
chaleureux pour le natif de trappes
passage au bizet passage par bonheur de
venir à skywest et le cinéma où je joue
je venais quand je sécher les cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui l'a d'abord comme il est
beau très beau
vous n'avez pas dit a dit quoi qu'il
était qu'il était quoi quand cette fois
il est notes un médecin filous qui
arrive dans la creuse dans les années 50
une libre adaptation de la pièce du même
nom écrite par jules romains en 1923 un
petit filou qui arrive dans ce petit
village de saint maurice avec un petit
projet un peu magnifique même un peu un
très très banal il vient d'en clairement
pour ce faire de l'oseille
mais heureusement il va être sauvée
comme être sauvées dans ce film yahia on
parle aussi de la rédemption la deuxième
chance il des choses qui peuvent se
modifier dans le bon sens dans les films
précédents en fait j'adapte et le texte
à mes personnages
et là j'ai dû adapter mon personnage aux
textes j'ai fait le travail inverse
c'est la première fois que je faisais ça
et c'était très intéressant
l'intérêt pour moi c'était de prendre
cette pièce et de l'emmener ailleurs et
c'est une c'est vraiment une très libre
adaptation on retrouve tout ce qui fait
la saveur le sel de cette pièce
les répliques cultes qui font partie de
notre mémoire collective et de notre
patrimoine littéraire mais pour autant
adapté c'est trahir avec laval
les éditions gallimard et de l'ayant
droit de jules romains j'ai vraiment
imaginer un passé en présent un avenir
j'ai appris son passé criminel tu as un
menteur reste un menteur
il m'a fallu tiers ses mille et un
petits métiers pour ne pas mourir de
faim et alors un film à la distribution
prestigieuse sabine azéma rufus ou
encore christian hecq n'a que 100 salles
ce mercredi 18 octobre
la population de saint maurice est bien
portante les gens bien portants sont les
malades qui s'ignorent monsieur le maire
[Musique]